hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have been requesting uh for
very good reasons sergeant eric gracie
has won the abu dhabi masters and he has
won it with um well a brilliant
brilliant score he had a seven and a
half out of nine and this is a game from
the final round argentina versus uh very
strong spanish grandmasters uh grand
master we've had him on the channel many
many times david
and it is uh
quite a brutal game i mean you can
really feel that it's it was played in
the final round and that both of them
are making sure they don't make a single
mistake and that you know they they will
do absolutely everything to win but they
will also do ever absolutely everything
not to give the other guy even a chance
to try and play for the win so it's a
really wild game and uh erigasi comes
into this game uh uh right after his
game where he defeated wang hao with the
black pieces so uh he had a brilliant
brilliant tournament and now he faces
david anton who is like i said an
incredible player let's check it out and
then we are going to discuss the uh the
the standings the the live rating list
and so on and before uh so many of you
start writing in the comments that is
not his rating i assure you it is um the
one that you are referring to is the
live rating so let's uh dive straight or
rather this was the rating uh during the
the the the actual tournament so let's
dive straight into it uh eric c opens
with e4 we have c6 uh david anton goes
for the karo khan defense we have d for
d5 and now e captures on the 5c capture
so the exchange variation and now c for
the pawn of attack
that's becoming more and more popular
against the karo khan it seems like you
shouldn't really have all that much
because you already traded all the
tension in the center and you will most
likely have an isolated d-pawn but you
will get some attacking chances
throughout the game so knight f6 we have
knight to c3 knight to c6 and knight to
f3 so nothing new here uh and the main
moves here for black are bishop to g4
and e6 but uh david anton wanted to uh
take uh
uh arjun out of his uh opening
preparation and he plays a6 and move
that's in or that that only has been
played a handful of uh times and of
course now uh it's still not completely
new territory but uh he he wants to make
sure that
he's not being the one getting out
prepared so bishop to g5 now putting
pressure on the center you are basically
threatening to pick up the knight and
then win the d5 pawn so bishop to e6
defending the pawn for the moment you
are uh preventing your e7 pawn from
being developed but your real plan is g6
and then bishop to g7 so here we have
bishop to e2 pawn to g6 and now bishop
captures on f6 if you don't do it now
then you're not going to do it after
bishop to g7 is played this way you can
at least ruin uh black spawn structure
so bishop captures e captures in here
arjun castles uh and there is uh one
game where bishop to g7 was played or
maybe even three games uh the most
notable one being um versus grand delus
that ended in a draw but here instead of
bishop g7 david anton goes bishop to e7
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game
so uh that's basically the the the
surprise he brought here uh which is odd
as he already prepared the effing
catering of the bishop with g6 but now
it is up to arjun to make
something out of this and here comes a
move that
is not recommended by an engine and that
is pawn to c5 it is a move that will
echo throughout the entire game and we
should uh you know really stare at that
pawn for for the rest of the game and
you will see why
uh so how do we react to this well uh
usually you have to be very careful when
making a move like this because you no
longer uh participate in the in the uh
well in the in the struggle of uh the
the central pawns now this d5 pawn is no
longer under pressure and black can uh
create the entire game uh around this
idea but also you control the b6 pawn
maybe if the knight comes to b6 could be
could be very ugly so how do you play
this well here we have pawn to f5 now
completely taking away d4 square from uh
from white and basically saying uh if i
can maybe re-maneuver my knight over
here let's see something right back here
knight e7 knight f6 knight to e4 my
position will be uh spectacular and here
already we have a move that is featured
in the thumbnail and the one that i was
very inspired by that for some reason
and that is pawn to b4 it's a beautiful
beautiful idea uh preparing rook b1 a4
and b5 and just uh completely in the
spirit of the pawn of attack just uh uh
taking control over the queen side and
saying i have the pawn uh advantage on
the queen side i will be able to create
a pass pawn here and if you're wondering
what happens if knight captures on b4
well i don't know what uh arjun had in
mind but probably something like rook to
b1 or queen b3 or queen to b1 basically
anything that attacks the knight and
after the knight moves let's say queen
b3 attacks the knight now if you move
the knight just queen captures on b7 or
if you defended just a3 we're still
gonna kick away the knight queen
captures on b7 and you have created a
past c pawn
uh that's um uh kind of the the idea so
after this uh ponte b4 move we have
castles by david anton and now rook to
b1 no longer this is an option but now
you know that a4 and b5 are coming so
here we have bishop to f6 putting
pressure on the d4 pawn and now pawn the
a4 we have g5 david anton says all right
i'm gonna push uh g4 take away uh this
knight from f3 and then i'm just gonna
win the d4 pawn so how can arjun stop
this well he starts with b5 now okay
okay you have to react to this as the
knight is being attacked a captures on
b5 and now although you would expect a
captures on b5 with hopes of getting a
pass pawn very soon arjun actually plays
bishop captures on b5 and this is a very
very
uh interesting move uh
it's a weird one because now you don't
have a pass pawn but at some point the
bishop captures can always be played b
captures and then you will have a past a
pawn and the past a pawn is usually
better than a past c pawn so here we
have knight the e7 and he also convinced
david anton that uh g4 is bad for him
but we also have to take into
consideration uh at the standings of the
tournament arjun is doing very well he's
half a point ahead of david anton so if
the david anton wants to have any chance
of winning the event he has to play for
a win here and g4 although objectively
best does not give a
black
a lot of winning chances for example
bishop captures b captures now you have
created a past a pawn now knight's the
e5 going after the c6 spawn but now you
just trade captures captures in d4 and
this is a very very good for black
knight to the e2 uh seemingly you're
gonna lose the pawn here but there's
bishop c for now uh preventing the
knight from from being moved and at some
point after rook t1 is played you will
trade here and you will always have this
past d-pawn so that's basically black's
counter play but still white has a past
a pawn it's not it's not a lot uh so
instead he goes knight to e7 doesn't
allow bishop captures on c6 like i said
if you allow this capture then b
captures this is a must and the a pawn
is created so bishop back to e2 and now
we have g4 now the knight is being
remaneuvered over the c2 and from c to
the knight will guard the d for pawn so
91 we have knight to c6 attacking the d4
pawn and not knight to c2 this is how
the pawn is defended we have rook to a7
uh adding another defender here uh and
the now pawn uh
uh
upon the f4 uh probably with the idea of
preventing black from
pushing e4 anytime soon f4 anytime soon
you will have to prepare it as the g4
pawn would fall but uh uh it's uh it's a
nice way of controlling the center so
here we have pawn to
pawn to h5 and now we have queen to d2
we have bishop back to g7 and now bishop
goes away all the way to b back all the
way to b5 now again captures captures
will be possible and the the past a pawn
will be created so h4 david anton
continues pushing on the king side and
now bishop captures on c6 uh arjun says
it is time to create a pass pawn so b
captures and now rook f the e1 uh bishop
back to d7 and now rook to b6 just uh
putting uh putting pieces on very very
optimal squares rookie eight offering a
trade of rooks now king f1 we have rook
capture sunny one king capture sun e1
and now queen to a8 putting pressure on
the a4 pawn for the moment you can't
really act on this because as long as
the knight covers the a4 pawn there
there is no capturing the pawn so knight
to b4 now putting pressure on c6 also
the queen from eight guards c6 that's uh
the main point the queen went there and
now king to f8
we have g3 and now bishop to e8
basically saying that um
i i really don't have a better move and
i know my f5 pawn is weak so at some
point if you attack it i can also shift
the queen over to c8 to defend this pawn
so queen d3 attacking f5 and queen to c8
defending the spawn we have king to d2
this is how arjun tries to fight for
advantage here he wants to remaneuver
the king all the way to a3 and then the
position will be
much much safer to try and push so here
bishop back to d7 uh we have king to c1
uh rook back to a8 and now queen to e3
uh we have bishop back to e8 and now
king to b2 rook to a7 and now just king
the a3 and here queen back to
a8 putting again pressure on a4 and
keeping an eye on the c6 pawn so here
king to b2 uh you could also play g
captures on h4 but uh arjun decides
against this uh like i said we have to
take into consideration that this is the
final round of the tournament uh a
victory here would mean the world to
both of them but a loss here would be
devastating as they have both had a
spectacular tournament so here came back
to b2 we have rook to e7 now attacking
the queen queen back to d2 we have rook
back to a7 queen to d3 and now queen to
c8 again defending the f5 pawn so king
a3
and now we have h captures on g3 before
repeating as like we've seen uh g
captures on h4 was it was an actual
threat and at some point i think davido
knew that arjuna would go for this so
each captures now bishop to d7 knight to
c2 now now the knight is going to be
remaneuvered maybe over to e3 to put
more pressure on f5 and prevent the
bishop queen duo from ever leaving the
defense of the f5 pawn so bishop to f6
knight to e3 and now kink the g7 uh we
have rook back to b1 uh and here uh even
though the f5 pawn is attacked um and it
doesn't seem like you have all that many
moves uh queen to h8 allowing arjun to
capture on f5 and this is basically your
only counterplay you you give up a pawn
and then you get the uh infiltrate with
the queen and maybe put pressure on the
on on the white king if a white uh white
allows it of course so knight captures
an f5 with check bishop captures queen
captures and now queen to h3 so now
david anton is down upon but he gets um
some wonderfully active squares for his
queen queen back to d3 guarding the g3
pawn queen to g2 we have rook to e1 and
now queen to f2 attacking rook on e1 and
also the pawn on d4 so the only move
that saves white is rook to e3 we have
queen back to g1 now hoping to get some
uh some checks in maybe queen a one
check maybe queen to c1 shackle
depending on what white plays so knight
the d1 not allowing this and also the
knight is very nicely placed here the
queen defends the knight knight defense
the rook rook defends the pawn so it
doesn't seem like the queen
really has all that much to do here and
here we have rook back to a8 uh you
can't really get the rook into the game
if you try something like rook b7 you go
for something there's really nowhere for
the roof to go white will just push the
pawn i mean rook a7 pawn to a6 and now
you've just improved the white's
position so instead rook to a8 now comes
queen to d2 and now we have queen to f1
uh instead of this queen to f1 uh the
idea maybe rook h8 the h1 is the is the
way to go for david anton but here we
have queen to f1 and now uh the the idea
okay if if maybe you start pushing the
pawn let's say the pawn is defended then
if your last time like queen b5 of
course the position is now completely
lost but of course arjun will not do
that after queen f1 he offers a queen
trade queen to d3 as he's up upon so uh
if queens get traded off uh chances are
he will have some winning chances so uh
here queen back to h1 rook to e2 and now
queen to f1
uh
yeah you don't have any any good
discoveries for example if you could
somehow deliver a check you could pick
up the queen
but you don't so here rook back to d2
offering a queen trade queen to e1 we
have queen to c3 and now queen back to
e7 david anton sees that he will have to
look for other ways to
attack the white king so knight the e3
now threatening knight f5 check that
will win the queen and the just queen to
a7 putting pressure on the a4 pawn and
now queen to c2 now the queen and king
defend the a4 pawn and of course black
cannot capture here queen to a5 and now
we have knight captures on g4
and this is a very very interesting
capture that sort of allows
black to improve his position we have
rooked the b8
and now comes knight captures
on f6 uh point is if you go back knight
to e3 and it seems like uh you you
should be able to do this uh queen to b
for check and now you are lost king to
a2 and now you're just gonna play rook
to a8 and there is no uh defending this
position because the a4 pawn will fall
so uh knight captures on f6 right away
and this is such a such a beautiful
position uh here arjun is saying that uh
queen b4 check followed by rook to a8 is
no longer playable here and indeed it
isn't because there would actually be a
forced checkmate in nine if david anton
goes for this i'm gonna show it because
it's beautiful uh so queen to be for
check king a2 and now if rook to a8 well
now the point is there's queen the h7
check and this will be a forced mate in
nine uh queen a7h7 check you give up the
knight and now queen the h6 with check
you force the king over to the uh to df
file or if you go king to e7 that's even
worse uh now uh like i said you have to
uh watch the c 5.4 for the entire game
because it is actually the advancement
of the c pawn and the control over the
d6 square uh that allows this because
now let's say queen d6 check only move
king 8 rook to e2 will be checkmate and
even if you don't go over to e7
uh if you uh if you go
to 5 it's not much better just queen to
g5 with check king e4 now queen the e5
would check the king hunt continues king
f3 queen to 82 with check characters and
now let's say regulator d3 check king h4
now queen to e7 with king h5 and queen
to g5 will be checkmate so that's the
problem uh with uh
going for this uh you you will have to
waste the move capturing uh on on f6 at
some point because you cannot allow this
you can play queen to b for check and
then capture uh but then of course uh
you will no longer have any any winning
chances so here king captures an f6
right away and now rook to h2 and again
now you have to calculate a whole lot
what if rook to h6 check what if the the
rook and queen start attacking the black
king well queen to be for check is
always useful so queen before uh king to
a2 and now again is rook to a8 possible
uh again if you play rook to a8 rook to
h6 is deadly and that's kind of why
origin put it there king e7 now queen to
e2 check and wherever you go the control
over the d sec d6 square is crucial so i
really hope you guys were uh you know
constantly uh keeping an eye on that c5
pawn let's say king d8 rook d6 check
king to c8 now of course the queen comes
into the game queen eight checking the
b7 rook the d7 check
king to a6 and of course queen captures
on a8 will be checkmate so uh that's why
when you have a a a pawn uh deep
this isn't even deep this is only the
fifth rank but it's uh even this can be
considered deep in your opponent's
position you already gain control over
two very very important squares that can
be used um throughout the game so queen
captures on d4 by david anton this is
the best best way to go and now rook to
h6 check now it's a little bit different
before because after queen king to e7
you no longer have the usual queen to
eight you check king to f8 and then rook
to h8 because now the queen is covering
the h8 square so king to f8 would be
very nice here if check was given so
instead we have rook captures and c6 now
creating a past c pawn as well and now
just rook to b4 going for rook captures
on a4 now comes rook to a6 defending the
pawn and here it's a really really
tricky position where you have to be
very very careful about what you do
you have to play rook to c4 you could
also play king to d8 it's a sort of the
cooler way to keep
control over the over the position but
basically rook to c4 is the only way for
you to uh hold this position if queen e2
then you can simply block uh so so you
don't have to worry about that and if
for example rook to a7 then king eight
and if you of course go after then uh
you can even lose this king b8 and now
both your rook and queen are hanging so
uh kink the d8 or rook to c4 the only
two moves that are possible but here
king to f8 was played and this uh
this position now allows arjun to make a
move that i'm sure you guys will have no
problem finding uh as you were you know
keeping an eye on on a certain something
for for the entire game so have at it
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course pawn to c6 that's the good stuff
the the pawn that advanced the c5 in a
sort of a
anti-positional manner now advances the
c6 and it becomes unstoppable uh but uh
you had to see more than one move you
actually had to see two moves ahead in
order to make this work because here
david anton just played rook to c4 and
he asks
what's your plan i'm attacking your
queen and also if the queen moves i'm
just gonna gobble up the a4 pawn uh with
checks so how do you how do you play
this well arjun's idea was queen b2 and
this is the only move that wins because
now there is no move for black that you
can make
obviously rook captures on a4 was played
but i'm going to show you some other fun
lines for example if you want to avoid
the queen trade let's say you move the
queen away from this diagonal then
that's just it rook to a8 with check
king to e7 and now queen to e5 will be
checkmate
so obviously you don't want to move the
queen away from this diagonal if you
trade queens seems like you can do this
but then just king captures and now look
at this rook end game white is up two
pawns and now even if black starts
pushing you can play a5 if pawn to d3
you put the rook behind the passport
let's say rook 8 checking to e7 now rook
a7 check the only move that wins but not
a difficult one to find because you kind
of want to put the rook on d7 king the
e6 and not rook to d7 and now uh there's
no way to defend the pawn you have to
trade captures captures and of course
three pawns against one is completely
winning so here david anton has to face
a very very unpleasant reality that
there is no move that you can make here
uh there is uh the the idea of uh trying
rook to c3 but it's such an ugly move
again queen to b8 check and there there
is no uh saving this position for
example rook to c3 queen to b8 check you
have to move and now queen to e5 check
forces the queen trade again the
position is completely winning for white
you have too many pawns here so here
after this a queen to beat you move uh
truly spectacular wait uh at the force
uh force a win here rook captures an a4
check was played and now you really see
the problem of king to f8 the king is on
f8 it's a dark square and now after rook
captures on a4 queen captures on a4 with
check it seems like you are checking the
king and winning the pawn uh queen the
a3 blocks and delivers check beautiful
stuff here so here uh it was in this
position on move 67 uh that david
antongiharo resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here we can
even show it as there are some maybe and
newer players
who might uh
you know not realize that this is
winning for example king to e7 king to
b4 and now after king to d6 you will
play king to b5 your opponent is
defended and that of course means that
the position is winning point is that
there are two ways black and played is
black and start pushing the pawn or
black can blockade your pawn but the
blockading isn't really all that
impressive just kink to c5 uh and that's
it uh there's really not much you can
play after the four captures captures
you are now uh i mean you have two pawns
your opponent has one and it's a very
very easily winning king d7 king f6 king
to e8 you know just push the pawns king
of fade g5 king to wherever king t8 f5
king here g6 captures captures king here
push the pawn uh you have to allow your
your opponent's king to have a square
here now we're just gonna push the king
here and of course uh bring a queen into
the game and checkmate the the black
king very soon so the only uh uh chance
uh you might have is instead of king to
c7 to go d4
but now you actually allow white to
queen this pawn so just king b6 and now
after d3 uh you're going to push c7 if
king here guarding this then just king
to be seven guarding this the the
queening square and if d2 c8 comes with
check the and now after the king was you
can play anything let's say queen to c2
pick up the pawn and then of course you
are completely winning so after this
queen the a3 check and absolute
brilliancy uh david anton kihara
resigned the game and arjun gets another
spectacular uh victory in the tournament
in the final round which of course
clinches in first place and he won it uh
with sulfur's place seven and a half
points um uh out of nine uh in second
place uh you know javakir sindarov also
uh a very very strong young player uh in
second place and then in third place we
have a whole lot of players like ray
robs and jordan panforest
uh aryan chopra somewhere
and um
those are basically the uh the top ten
but then uh someone wrote that there are
uh top five in the first top ten are are
indian players and then even uh morley
kartakiyan is like in eleventh place so
uh indians really really did well uh in
this event uh but uh arjun uh wins wins
first place and that is without question
uh and also uh here i just wanted to
show you guys these were his opponents
uh in the event so he started off
with two nice wins against uh rohit
krishna and the deep sanggupta then a
win against the grand master alexander
indic uh then two draws against two very
very strong grand masters evgeny
tomaszewski nerd and panforest then a
victory against uh his countrymen raunak
salvani then a draw against ray robson
and then a victory against van gaal an
incredibly strong player 27 35 uh and
that brought him to uh face the uh the
the final round boss david haro that he
also defeated so seven and a half out of
nine truly truly incredible and what
does this mean for the uh for the live
rating list well we can check it out so
this is the live rating list you can see
that um uh arjunargasy is now he won he
won 35.6 points uh since the
last rating count so that's truly
incredible you can see that he jumped 24
uh places that's incredible you can see
that you know people usually move up one
square two squares you know three four
uh but 24 that is that is just sick i
mean that's truly incredible and he uh
almost catches up to ghoukesh he is now
on 27-24 gurkish is on 27
27 and they are the
the top three uh players in india
of course including vishwanathan anand
who is still almost in the top 10 he is
currently number 12 with 2756 but that
is uh uh they still have quite a lot to
catch up to him if they have an uh like
if they pull off two more events like
this then it's possible but i mean uh
pulling off an event like this will not
be easy but as you've seen they are uh
doing it pretty consistently and uh
it i mean it could become a possibility
very very soon uh so yeah that's the
game the standings the live ratings the
the everything um i hope you guys
enjoyed that really an incredible game
like both of them really played the win
and not to lose and that's why you know
it took uh it took absolutely everything
in order to be able to win this game but
what what a game it was uh so yeah sorry
about a bit of a longer video i now see
that it's 25 minutes long sorry about
that but i mean the lines were truly
amazing so hope you enjoyed that
i would like to i wish a very happy
birthday to chris's brother uh slunky
jim and i would like to thank michael
paul huda uh chris basil gregory obama
and conor kelly for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens uh in the chess
world at the saint louis rapid and blitz
tournament has started so most likely a
few games from that event
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day